you won't have an advantage like the
politicians have and normal people when
they do insider trading they get
arrested they faced real prosecution
they face the the justice system going
down breathing down their necks and
putting them in jail going down I was
like where are you going
straight yeah get your hand out of it
Martha Stewart head out of the gun she
was worth it she's a billionaire she
went to jail for six months absolutely
75 000 trade yeah why aren't these
Congress members why aren't these
Senators is it because they're insider
trading and then we also have to
understand how nasty this is especially
when it comes to so many people
struggling financially this is this is a
game there's winners and there's losers
they rigged the system so they are
always the winners who's the losers
everyone else all the other peasants the
people who have their retirements
accounts in the stock market that of
course are guaranteed to lose because
these people are rigging the game for
the benefit of themselves so so this is
absolutely seedy disgusting Behavior
especially when it comes to so many
people being poor so many blue collar
workers being screwed over